literally it's time for the draft best
non-quarterbacks in the afc east trivia
question for you chris
name
the giants and jets to make cameo
appearances in the sopranos one of each
one of each
i know one of them
i know like you know i'm i'm i watched
the sopranos back in the day i'm not as
good as like you and matt casey who i
think still watch like reruns and all
that all right
man who was the jets guy i want to say
i'm going to go with michael strahan
on the sopranos is that right no of the
jets no no the giants of course but i'm
wrong about that anyways all right the
jets i was going to go i'm trying to
think of the time period of what makes
sense there
i i really do not remember i think time
period and ethnicity
oh
oh
so you're telling me there was an
italian stallion on the jets that i
can't think of there that i'm i'm
missing all right i give up i'm wrong i
don't know does anyone call him a
stallion especially not bill belichick
eric mangini oh man genius that's right
man i
yeah uh what were they at like a
restaurant and he sees them there for
the first time right isn't that what
happens
they were at vesuvio and he went to say
hi to the man genius also sir lawrence
of the meadowlands for the giants a guy
who recently signed a jersey
bad
mother something it was lawrence
yeah man you know i i gosh i thought i
remembered lawrence in there but i
couldn't remember so i went with michael
strahan but uh all right good yeah
that's any given sunday not a great
movie but lawrence taylor was really
good in that well yeah i mean he played
himself i mean so it wasn't hard
you know he got to play a crazy psycho
outside linebacker in a lot of ways so
yeah agreed lawrence was pretty damn
good in it for sure
all right i'm glad i got the first pick
in this one because there's one guy that
stands out above all others and then it
gets difficult give me stefan diggs
after that who the hell knows but i'm
taking stefan diggs yeah i i hear you i
think he is certainly right there in the
the conversation for that um
you know he's just too he's he's the
best receiver
and i guess he really you know you look
at it and you go he's the the best maybe
offensive weapon in the division at
least right now as we sit here so uh i'm
not mad at you he was one of the first
he was the first name i wrote down too
mike um i'm gonna go with xavier howard
i think that's the next guy i'm going
with you know
without a doubt one of the best corners
in football got the best ball skills at
any corner in football that's for sure i
mean catches the ball like a wide
receiver ball gets around him catches it
you know plays a lot of man-to-man
coverage in that brian flores scheme so
he covers the the top receiver of the
second receiver follows him around the
field all of those type of things xavier
howard in all facets of coverage is
phenomenal so i'll go with him
that was my second guy uh without
question
very very good look at this pick here we
got the catch i remember this one
[Music]
wow yeah pulling it in with his right
arm tucking it away and hitting the
ground and holding on to it i'm gonna go
with the guy that the patriots have done
their best to hide i am
and and even though they applied the
second round tender nobody offered him a
contract i guess they thought it might
match it i don't know he'll be an
unrestricted free agent next year jc
jackson i think he overcame stefan
gilmore last year uh the interception
totals were i think he was close to yeah
right there
right behind no doubt but but they've
done their best not a starter wasn't on
the pro bowl roster right uh but uh it's
it i i it's it's clear that that he's a
legitimate piece of that defense and
they're gonna have a hell of a decision
to make after this year because i don't
think he's gonna fall in line with the
patriot way and and take whatever they
offer and just be happy to stay in new
england no that's right i mean he's a
i'm trying to think off the top of my
head here jc jackson was he a free agent
or late round pick right uh or i can't
undrafted free undrafted free agent
where this is again where you're
scouting and due diligence i mean this
guy was one of the top recruits yeah he
had a little few off the field issues in
college that's really what led him to
being undrafted he had he had a transfer
schools all those things but new england
knowing all that information and
recognizing the talent never kept their
eye off of them and i'm with you you
know i mean we remember me talking about
it last year they would start mccordy
the first drive of the game and i'd go
there mccordy let three pack catches for
a touchdown and now they're down seven
nothing because yeah they wanted to be
able to say jc jackson wasn't starting
for contract negotiation purposes
what and let's fast forward let's say
they get to the super bowl will jc
jackson be curiously benched the entire
game as he heads to free agency like
malcolm butler was four years ago i say
that only half joking i it is it's you
never know i mean you're right you never
know and you can break you know a really
who knows a simple rule anything you
never know with bill he'll he'll he
could he could you know hold everybody
accountable that way i i think i gotta
man i don't really wanna do this but i i
think i gotta go the corner opposite of
jc jackson i gotta go stefan gilmore i
do i mean he's still for me he's still
one of the five best corners in the game
you know and i listen i think you know
the two guys in baltimore jaylen ramsey
xavier and howard the two guys you just
mentioned i don't know those might be
and jair alexander those might be the
top corners in the game for me right now
but gilmore
you know a little bit of a down year
last year we know that he had the injury
missed some games and all that but still
i mean top-notch player i don't know if
this will be the last year in new
england or whatever but he's still got
some really good years left in front of
him still has his speed still tackles
willingly he's smart with how he plays
the position and everything like that
and just like the other guys he's an
island corner oh i got this guy cool all
right coach do whatever you got to do
with the rest of the defense uh i always
love those kind of corners
one of the few guys belichick paid
market value to before this year and uh
worked out well after seeing him for
five years with the bills they knew
exactly what they were getting and he's
taken his game to an even higher level
so i like that one i'm gonna go quentin
williams next i want to give the big guy
some love look it's hard when you're an
interior defensive lineman to justify
that that draft status unless you're
aaron donald you don't get a ton of
sacks i feel like he's moving in the
right direction though i think we saw
some of it last year and now they get
some better players around it right and
maybe get a little better offense so
you're in some better situations on
defense where you're not getting
steamrolled and and the offense is
pressing and maybe you can disrupt even
more and pin the years back as defensive
lineman do when you actually have a lead
in a game i think we're going to see
even more from williams this year agreed
he was he was he was borderline dominant
at the end of the year you know you
asked the rams how they how they felt
about quentin williams when the when the
the jets beat them that day how they
couldn't two guys couldn't block him you
know he he
i think really like you're saying kind
of took that step to go like okay
he looks like a top five pick now like
yeah i think he's there and your points
i think with the supporting cast around
him are only are correct one the
defensive scheme i think will fit him
two hey now the defensive lines got to
think about sheldon rankins and carl
lawson you know rushing the quarterback
and blocking them so he should be able
to see some favorable matchups but i i i
think there's a good chance we're
talking about him as one of the better
d-linemen in football when this season's
over um all right i'm gonna stay with
the jets too i'm gonna give another i'm
gonna give ej moseley a little love here
a guy that's long forgotten you know
hurt his groin you've forgotten you've
forgotten his first initial he's been
gone for so long i i i i what did i say
you said ej
what what what what the hell is this cj
oh my gosh i'm an idiot
oh my gosh i don't know where i had that
name in my head but yeah cj mosley i
mean he had that groin injury right two
years ago last year he opted out you
know again it's i don't know exactly
where he is but i can't imagine he's
falling off a cliff to the point to
where he's still not one of the better
inside linebackers in football i mean
that's remember week one 2019.
nothing in the first half he was
phenomenal he injured the groin and the
whole
right exactly right so i i mean again he
was so good before that and i would have
a hard time thinking he's not going to
be real good again this year
you know i had him on the list but i
thought i thought if i pick him you're
going to give me a hard time because he
hasn't done anything i know no i know no
i think he's too talented and i just
he's not old enough for me to think oh
the year out of the game hurt him or
anything like that so i'm playing he's
back with vengeance this year
i hate to go back to the patriots
because they had two guys on already but
you know that's okay the jets just went
back to back hey johnny smith the first
guy that they signed just minutes into
free agency he he was great with the
titans last year underrated because you
got derrick henry and you got aj brown
you got ryan tannehill but i i i think
that was a great move by the patriots we
know how
important the tight end is in their
offense he's got hunter henry there to
take some heat off i think henry and
smith together will be great i think
smith
even though henry got the franchise tag
with the chargers so you end up thinking
he's better better than someone who
never did i still think smith
right now a notch above
right now a guy who's ready to explode
and become household name in new england
and possibly beyond yeah agree i mean
they gave him more guaranteed money than
henry you know i know it was one more
year on the contract but i think that
does say something to what they think
the talent of that guy is you know and
yes i think this is jonu smith from a
talent standpoint is up there as far as
the physical ability of all the good
tight ends in football now he's going to
be in an offense and everything that
really knows how to use him and things
like that to where i think he he you
know shows everybody what he's got
you know when you sit here and do this
exercise
i i have the most patriots written down
the patriots team is the one that has
more than any other team to me
you know and i'm going to go back to
them you know because as i sit here
right now
the best edge defender in the division
is matt judon who also was just signed
by the patriots you know i know there's
carl lawson with the jets you know maybe
the dolphins with jalen phillips who i'm
honestly thinking about their first
round pick taking him here as this draft
continues but you know i just look at
matt judon and yeah maybe he's not going
to be a 12 14 sacks a year type guy but
it's going to be a lot of 8 and 10 and a
lot of other great things he does for
your defense that don't go on the stat
sheet and that's why belichick and them
signed him and like him so i'll go matt
judon
you know i'm really really stuck here
yeah we've got one buffalo bill davious
white's on the board still
i know i'm thinking about him but he
he's not the guy that he was before he
got out of extension no
so
i'll go makai bechten i like what he did
last year and i like what he's going to
do as he continues to develop in his nfl
career uh that that's three jets and one
bill
um oh boy uh i
and and only one dolphin and they're on
the cusp as well but i i got i gotta go
mckay back then that's the guy that i
would take out all the names left it's
it's a division that lacks superstars
but has a whole lot of good and depth
that's what i think when you look at
these teams you just go man they're well
constructed they might not be the
superstar headline type of guys but you
just go wow good player good player i'm
stuck between
you know there's trudavius trent brown
is in the division which i still think
he's going to be one of the better right
tackles of football i'm going to go with
byron jones down in miami i'm going
another damn corner i mean you just tell
you byron jones when healthy to me is
again in that conversation with some of
the other corners we've talked about
here last year he played through
injuries but man he there's a reason the
dolphins paid him a boatload of money
because he's an island guy that can
cover anybody in football so i'll go
with him there it was a tough one as
close between these other guys
this was the toughest division so far
there aren't superstars beyond stefan
diggs and maybe xavier howard it's very
difficult
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports